ينضم الينا في الاستديو الدكتور ابراهيم
خطيب استاذ اداره النزاعات والخبير في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه مرحبا بك دكتور
ابراهيم لو بدانا من ما ذكرته و ستريت
جورنال عن توتر يتصاعد بين بايدن ونتنياهو
لان المسؤولون الامريكيون غير راضين عن
مسار الحرب عن
كثره الشهداء من المدنيين
عن ان انه لا يتم التزام بهد
اطول كيف يمكن ان نفهم ما يحصل وما ابعاده
طبيعه العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل كانت علاقات مركبه خصوصا قبل
الحرب كان هناك علاقه سيئه بين بايدن
ونتنياهو لفتره طويله ثم تبعها تحسن في
العلاقات عند اذا اذا كنا نذكر قبل الحرب
كل الان الحديث الان عن الحرب ولكن قبل
الحرب كان هناك حديث متقدم حول تطبيع في
المنطقه كانت تقود الولايات المتحده بشكل
اساسي بتنسيق مع اسرائيل وهذا ح حسن نوعا
ما العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
لتاتي الحرب من جديد لتضع العلاقه
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه على مفترق طرق
ويقرر بايدن الذهاب بدعم كامل لاسرائيل
هذا الدعم ايه من طرف بايدن لاسرائيل تمثل
باعطاء مظله دبلوماسيه سياسيه امريكيه
للحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه ويبدو ان
بايدن كان مدركا انه ضريبه هذه المظله ان
يكون هناك اصغاء اسرائيلي لمطالب الولايات
المتحده وهذا الاصغاء كان متمثلا في ثلاث
اتجاهات الاولى الاصغاء في ف الانساني
الجانب الاخر الاصغاء في الملفات المرتبطه
بملف المحتجزين والتعامل مع هذا الملف
والجانب الثالث هو ان يكون هناك يعني رؤيه
اسرائيليه امريكيه مشتركه للمستقبل
السياسي لقطاع غزه ويبدو ان اسرائيل يعني
لم تتعامل بشكل جدي مع مع مطالب الولايات
المتحده وحاولت المناوره وهذا مرتبط
بشخصيه نتنياهو نحن نعرف نتنياهو انه
مناور من الدرجه الاولى وهذا يبدو انه
ازعج البيت الابيض وا يعني جعل نتنياهو
يترا ع بعض الشيء في بعض الخطوات كان
اخرها موضوع ادخال الوقود لقطاع غزه وذلك
بضغط امريكي وبالتالي هذه العلاقه
المتوتره بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
قائمه ولكن هذا لا يعني تخلي الولايات
المتحده نتحدث عن البيت الابيض عن عن
اسرائيل في هذه المرحله ولكن حديث الوسي
جورنال هو بالتحديد كما ذكرت دكتور
ابراهيم عن القلق من خطط اسرائيل النهائيه
فيما يتعلق بقطاع غزه هذا القلق ان استمر
كيف يمكن ان يبدل من الموقف الامريكي لما
تقوم به اسرائيل يعني حتى الان يعني
الولايات المتحده كانت تتحدث عن مرحله ما
بعد ما بعد غزه ويبدو اننا يعني في خضام
المعركه لا يمكن الحديث عن المستقبل في في
خضام المعركه ولا نعرف نتائجها وكيف
ستتقدم الامور ولكن الولايات المتحده في
دخولها ودعمها لاسرائيل كانت يعني واضعه
نصبع عينيها على الاقل وفق التصريحات
الرسميه ان هناك حاجه لعمليه سياسيه
ولتحريك القضيه الفلسطينيه في اتجاه حل
الدولتين وهذا لم توافق عليه اسرائيل يعني
اسرائيل كانت واضحه نتنياهو كان واضحا انه
لن يوافق على حل الدولتين وان استخدم
تعابير انهم يريدون القضاء على حماس
ويريدون تغيير الوضع في قطاع غزه ولاحقا
تحدث عن انهم لا يريدون احتلال غزه انما
يريدون تواجد عسكري وبالتالي الولايات
المتحده ترى انه لا افق سياسي تطرحه
اسرائيل وهذا يشكل تحديا امام الدعم
الامريكي لاسرائيل في هذه المرحله خصوصا
امام الراي العام الامريكي الذي يعني يريد
ان يرى ايه افقا سياسيا في المنطقه
وبالتالي هذا سيشكل حاجزا امام استمرار
الدعم الامريكي لاسرائيل وان كان هذا
الحاجز مرتبط بان تطلب الولايات المتحده
بشكل مباشر من اسرائيل ان تضع افق سياسي
لمستقبل المنطقه ومستقبل قطاع غزه مجددا
وفق الرؤيه الامريكيه الاسرائيليه المعركه
ما زالت قائمه وهنا اشير السي الى نقطه
يعني اثارها نتنياهو البارحه في مؤتمره
الصحفي نتنياهو مع بدايه الحرب اشار الى
هدف وهو ما سماه القضاء على حماس ثم اضاف
هدف اضافي وارجاع المحتجزين والبارحه كان
هدف ثالث وضعه نتنياهو في مؤتمره الصحفي
وهو و ما بعد هذه الحرب ان لا تكون سلطه
فلسطينيه وفقا تعبير نتنياهو داعمه
للارهاب وبالتالي هو وضع هدفا اضافيا ل
لحربه هذه مت بدا يتحدث عن تبديل ثقافي في
غزه وتغيير ثقافي صحح وبتالي هذا متصل ب
رؤيه الولايات المتحده لمستقبل ما بعد غزه
وهنا نقاط الخلاف بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل اليوم يبدو وكان هناك حراك فيما
يتعلق بامكانيه القيام بصفقه لتبادل بعض
ال اسرى ايه سعي حثيث
من مختلف الاطراف ما الجديد بهذا الشان
باعتقادك
وما ما الذي يمكن ان يفتح عليه النجاح في
مثل هكذا صفقه يعني خلال الاسبوع او
الاسبوعين الماضيين كل كل حديث كان على
موضوع الصفقات وامكانيه وجود صفقه في ملف
ال الاسرى والمحتجزين او الرهائن وفقا
التعبير الاسرائيلي هؤلاء هذا الملف كان
مفتوحا ط طيله الوقت وشكل تحديا امام
نتنياهو الان السؤال المركزي هل نضجت
الظروف لهذه الصفقه وهذا وهذا يشكل يعني
يعني مربط ال الفرس في في هذا النقاش
واعتقد انه بالفعل هناك صار نضوج لا لا
نستطيع الجزم اذا كان هناك نضوج نهائي في
هذا الملف ولكن هناك ثلاث عوامل اساسيه
تشير الى هذا التوجه الاول ازدياد الضغط
الشعبي الاسرائيلي في هذا الملف المظاهرات
التي كانت في تل ابيب البارحه وفي القدس
تشير الى ازدياد الضغط الاسرائيلي في هذا
الجانب وحتى حديث وايزن كوت في لقائه مع
اسر هؤلاء المحتجزين انهم وضعوا اولويه
اعلى لملف المحتجزين على الاولويه الاولى
التي
كانت وفق وفق المصادر الاسرائيليه او وفق
التعابير الاسرائيليه القضاء على حماس
وبالتالي هناك تغيير في الاولويه او وضع
اولويه المحتجزين وهذا لديه دلاله معينه
الامر الاخر الذي يعني ممكن ان يكون انضج
الظروف لهذه الصفقه هو نحن الان على اعتاب
اليوم الخامس في اليوم ال 4ام لهذه الحرب
ولم يتم انجاز اطلاقها او يعني انجاز واضح
وحقيقي في اطلاق هؤلاء المحتجزين من خلال
من خلال الحرب ومن خلال الحرب البريه التي
كانت علما ان الجيش الاسرائيلي اشار ان
احد اهداف الحرب البريه هو اطلاق هؤلاء
الجانب الثالث الذي يشير الى الانجاز في
هذا الجانب هو ما تحدثنا عنه قبل قليل
الضغط الولايات المتحده الضغوط الدوليه في
ملف الهدن الانسانيه وتبادل تبادل
المحتجزين وهذا يبدو انه بات ضاغطا بشكل
كبير على على على اسرائيل في هذه المرحله
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور ابراهيم خطيب استاذ
اداره النزاعات والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه
شكرا